♪ ♪
>> Martha: THE CDC ISSUED NEW
GUIDELINES TODAY IN A 60 PAGE
REPORT ON HOW TO SAFELY REOPEN
SCHOOLS AND RESTAURANTS AND MASS
TRANSIT.
IT ALSO INCLUDED A WARNING THAT
SOME INSTITUTIONS SHOULD STAY
CLOSED FOR NOW.
SNEEZE GUARDS ON THE SCHOOL
BUSES AND EATING CLASS LUNCHES
NOT IN CAFETERIAS.
AND AS WE’VE ALL BEEN WIPING
DOWN HER GROCERIES AND LEAVING
STUFF OUTSIDE, IN THE NEW REPORT
THEY FOUND THAT THE VIRUS DOES
NOT SPREAD EASILY FROM TOUCHING
SURFACES OR OBJECTS.
HERE NOW TO HELP US WORK THIS
OUT HIS FORMER CDC DIRECTOR
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT OF THE ROBERT WOOD
JOHNSON FOUNDATION.
HE IS ALSO UNDER NEW JERSEY
GOVERNOR PHIL MURTHY TO
McMURPHY’S REOPENING TEAM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU, IT’S GREAT TO BE
HERE.
>> Martha: WHAT HE THINK ABOUT
THAT?
IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE WE
WERE TOLD ORIGINALLY THAT ALL
THE SCARY STORIES ABOUT HOW IT
HANGS IN THE AIR FOR 24 HOURS
AND IF IT LANDS ON METAL IT’S
THERE FOR 48 TO 72 HOURS, OR ON
PACKAGES.
THAT WAS REALLY A BIT OF THE
EARLY PANIC AND ALL OF THIS.
WHY WOULD THAT CHANGE?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY IT WOULD BE SO VALUABLE TO
HEAR FROM CDC SCIENTISTS EVERY
DAY.
WHEN A NEW INFECTIOUS AGENT
APPEARS, WHAT WE DON’T KNOW FAR
EXCEEDS WHAT WE DO KNOW, SO
THERE’S WORK THAT’S DONE IN
LABORATORIES.
THAT MAY SAY, WE FOUND IN THE
LABORATORY THIS SURVIVES FOR A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS ON
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES AND
WE CAN FIND IT IN THE AIR.
WHAT YOU THEN NEED TO DO IS SAY
OKAY, LET’S LOOK IN THE
COMMUNITY, WHAT ARE THE
IMPORTANT WAYS THIS IS SPREADING
AND THAT’S WHERE YOU CAN SEE, IN
THE LABORATORY YOU FOUND THAT
BUT WE FOUND IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT IT’S REALLY BEING CLOSE TO
SOMEONE WHO IS SICK, WITHIN
6 FEET, THAT IS THE IMPORTANT
THING IN THOSE OTHER WAYS ARE
NOT SO IMPORTANT.
>> Martha: IT BASICALLY SAYS
THAT BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CLOSE CONTACT WITHIN 6 FEET,
YOUR RESPIRATORY DROPLETS,
COUGHING, SNEEZING, ALL THE WAY
WE WOULD ANTICIPATE IN A NORMAL
SITUATION, THIS IS MUCH MORE
CONTAGIOUS, SO WHY IS IT, DO, SO
MUCH MORE CONTAGIOUS, OR IS IT?
>> THERE’S STILL A LOT OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
WHEN I COMPARE IT TO SOMETHING
LIKE THE FLU, THE FLU SPREADS
REALLY EASILY BETWEEN CHILDREN.
CHILDREN GET SICK, THEY SPREAD
IT TO EACH OTHER AND BRING IT
HOME.
ONE UNANSWERED QUESTION IS HOW
IMPORTANT ARE THEY IN
TRANSMISSION BECAUSE WE ALL WANT
TO GET OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL
THIS FALL IN IF WE CAN
UNDERSTAND, HOW DO WE DO THAT IN
A SAFE WAY.
AS A PARENT, AS A PEDIATRICIAN I
WANT TO KNOW THAT THE SAFEGUARDS
ARE IN PLACE TO LIMIT THE RISKS
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WE CAN’T ELIMINATE IT BUT CAN WE
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMFORTABLE GETTING THEIR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL?
>> Martha: LET’S HOPE.
ONE THING THAT HAS TAKEN ON A
LOT OF SIGNIFICANCE IS GETTING
EVERYTHING REOPENED.
AS I MENTIONED YOU ARE ON
GOVERNO REOPENING TEAM.
I SPOKEN TO A LOT OF DOCTORS WHO
SAY WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
WORK, THIS IS FROM A GROUP OF
600 DOCTORS WHO WROTE A LETTER
TO THE PRESIDENT URGING THE END
OF THE SHUT DOWN THEY SAY THE
MILLIONS OF CASUALTIES THAT THE
SHUTDOWN WILL BE HIDING IN PLAIN
SIGHT, ALCOHOLISM, HOMELESSNESS,
HEART ATTACK, STROKE OR KIDNEY
FAILURE, FINANCIAL INSTABILITY,
DRUG ADDICTION, DESPAIR,
UNPLANNED PREGNANCIES, POVERTY
AND ABUSE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT, DOCTOR?
>> THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
THINGS.
YES, PEOPLE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
WORK BUT ONE CONCERN I HAVE IS
PUBLIC HEALTH IS PUT UP AS THE
ENEMY INSTEAD OF AS THE ROAD
MAP.
WE WANT WORKERS TO GET BACK TO
WORK BUT IT SHOULD BE DONE IN A
WAY WHERE THEY FEEL SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE THAT ALL THE
PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE AND WE
WANT PEOPLE TO GO BACK TO
BUSINESSES, BUT THEY HAVE TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT GOING INTO
A STORE OR RESTAURANT WON’T PUT
THEM AT INCREASED RISK.
DATA, UNDERSTANDING WHERE THIS
IS TRANSMITTING AND WHERE IT’S
NOT, PLACES WHERE IT’S GOING
DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY AND THEY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO TEST PEOPLE AND
FIGURE OUT WHO THEY’VE HAD
CONTACT WITH AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN A SAFE PLACE
SO THAT THEY DON’T SPREAD IT TO
OTHERS, THEN YEAH, THOSE OF THE
MEASURES.
SO SEEING THIS GUIDANCE FROM CDC
WILL GIVE A LOT OF VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO BUSINESSES, TO
SCHOOLS, TO CONSUMERS SO THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW TO DO THIS
IN A SAFE WAY.
>> Martha: A LOT OF PEOPLE
NEED TO IN NEW YORK AND NEW JERS
ARE DESPERATE TO GET BACK TO
THEIR LIVES.
HOPEFULLY THE COUNCIL THAT YOU
ARE ON THE NEW JERSEY WILL HELP